Riverdale fan news I know that mark and
Kelly's son is now on Riverdale and have
you started what do you think Kelly will
do we're gonna get her on the show
obviously next so like what part do you
want her to play have you talked about
it have you guys faced time like what
does that happen yeah Michael is playing
the young Hyrum who you know he's a
spitting image of his old man so he's
crazy
he also sounds exactly like him too but
now I haven't heard anything about
Kellie joining the show and you talk so
when that'd be great or is that too many
cuts Wallace is with us on this end
great I'm not opposed KJ app' giving us
all the Riverdale tease of our dreams
it's about more than just Khalil
it's about black people report people
everybody at the bottom I need to speak
for him while promoting his new flick
the hate you give with his co-stars at
the Toronto International Film Festival
how nice was it after the couple years
that you've had to like let go of the
red hair and Archie and that fandemonium
and be a part of something with this
sense of gravitas yeah it was a dream
come true I that the dates and the
timing of it worked out perfectly yeah
and and I do you know any opportunity
that I get to step out of Archie and to
get out of the red here I will take with
a smile on my face so it was even I was
even lucky to be a part of the film that
was so important one of the things that
I think is really great about this movie
is that it sort of shows the aftermath
of the things that we see on the news
maybe for a week or news cycle how much
pressure did you feel to get that right
and do that justice since that's not
always a story that's told yeah I mean
this is like one of the first things of
its of its kind and so it is a lot of
pressure because you do have so many
people who rely on it you have so many
people from like the hood relying on you
have so many people who have to
assimilate and go to different school
rely on
and the people who have had family
members like myself who's been taken by
police brutality oh it's so much riding
on it and we just hope that people love
it and feel represented star in this
movie she's living these two different
lives do you guys ever feel that way
with your celebrity lives it's like one
of your lives is I have all these
followers and I'm famous and I'm can see
myself on television in the movies and
then the other is like I have to fold my
laundry and like pack my bags and like
go through airport security and might be
a normal human do you ever feel torn
between those two things
well just from me personally I actually
try and separate the two you know and I
try and have two separate worlds as
opposed to trying and putting them all
together
totally out because you know the but
working with humans and we do need the
time just for ourselves
I suppose they're just kind of sharing
everything with everyone and making
everything super public so you know I
think it's yeah there's there's two
different lives that you know I kind of
want to meet so I guess the answer to
your question is yes yeah me too Keltie
night she's here right now yeah but then
when you're at home you know yeah
[Music]
[Applause]